[Musique]
nous allons parler de bouffe maintenant
si j'ose dire puisque c'est un mot qui
est devenu à la mode et qui est passé
dans le langage courant avec un sondage
que vient de réaliser notre confrère qui
paraît en fin de semaine vsd et qui nous
indique que 83% des français préfère
inviter leurs amis à la maison plutôt
qu'au restaurant
je trouve que c'est bon signe alors vous
allez voir qu'il y a plus de valeur du
tout puisque le fameux steak frites est
maintenant relégué pour il a été
remplacé à la première place dans la
préoccupation des français
préoccupations du goût par le gigot
flageolets ce qui ne semble pas vouloir
décevoir monsieur claude chabrol c'est
ce que nous montre maintenant française
champé 83% des français préfère inviter
leurs amis à la maison plutôt qu'au
restaurant le plat de choix et gigot
flageolets claude chabrol célèbre pour
sa recette du poulet au vinaigre
ressemble-t-il à ses compatriotes
vous avez été souvent des gens a dit ne
jamais pourquoi parce que je garde mon
homme tombe - et
elle me fait elle me fait la cuisine à
moi le plat délicieux que je n'aime pas
le seul plat délicieux que je n'aime pas
c'est le boeuf carotte qui dans ce
sondage les carottes ne vient pas en
premier il ya seulement 6 % de français
qui aiment beaucoup
par contre c'est le gigot flageolets qui
arrive en tête qu'est ce que vous en
pensez je pense qu'ils ont tort de
préférer les flageolets aux gros poutous
la jil aigrot 60 je trouve que c est là
où il a pu ré samedi quel que soit vous
d'un pur et oui bien sûr mais il faut
que le boudin soit très bon la purée
aussi d'un pont ce soir le petit salé
aux lentilles du puy salé aux lentilles
non parce que toi je ne ferai pas de
puce à l'oreille parce que le bug selon
ti roupille at war et le colin pommes
vapeur sont et manger en angleterre où
151 fonctions
le chevelu vous aimez manger
oui je ne vous le cacherai pas oui et le
résume en fait de temps en temps non je
ne fais pas de régime parce que je suis
très basse alors je n'ai pas besoin de
me surveiller vous voyez je peux manger
autant que je veux je un jeu reste
toujours dans les mêmes poitras
[Musique]